There were moments all day long,...
...all day long,...
...just like that five-second moment in bed...
...where I knew knowledge, what I should do,...
...and if I didn't move within five seconds,...
...my brain would step in and talk me out of it.
Every human being has a five-second window.
It might even be shorter for you.
You have about a five-second window...
...in which you can move from idea to action...
...before your brain kicks into full gear...
...and sabotages any change in behavior.
Because remember, your brain is wired to stop you...
...from doing things that are uncomfortable or uncertain or scary.
It's your job to learn how to move from those ideas...
...that could change everything...
...into acting on them in the smallest moment.